[THE EU IS COMMITTED TO CUT EMISSIONS
BY AT LEAST 55% BY 2030]
[THE ENERGY SECTOR IS KEY
BECAUSE IT PRODUCES 75% OF OUR EMISSIONS]
[WE NEED TO USE LESS ENERGY
AND WE NEED CLEANER ENERGY SOURCES]
[BY 2030 40% OF THE ENERGY USED IN THE EU
SHOULD COME FROM RENEWABLE SOURCES]
[WE SHOULD USE AT LEAST 9% LESS ENERGY
THAN CURRENTLY PLANNED]
[ENERGY TAXATION SHOULD BE BASED ON
THE ENVIRONMENTAL IMPACT OF THE FUELS WE USE]
[TAXES ON CLEAN FUELS SHOULD BE LOWER
THAN TAXES ON MORE POLLUTING FUELS]
[WE WILL REMOVE THE TAX EXEMPTIONS
FOR KEROSENE FUEL FOR PLANES]
[AND HEAVY OIL FOR SHIPS
ON JOURNEYS WITHIN THE EU]
[THE MOST POLLUTING FUELS
SHOULD HAVE THE HIGHEST TAXES]
[BUT THERE WILL BE EXEMPTIONS]
[FOR VULNERABLE
AND ENERGY POOR HOUSEHOLDS]
[FOR THEIR HEATING FUELS
AND ELECTRICITY]